[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to discuss life in the harry
potter universe after the battle of
hogwarts and deathly hallows harry
potter and ginny weasley's marriage
produced three children
unlike their parents most of the potter
children lived a peaceful quiet life
but surprisingly one of them an ugly
duckling sorted into slytherin nearly
resurrected lord voldemort and destroyed
the wizarding worlds we know it
so who exactly worm harry's children and
what legacy do they leave behind
join us as we answer these questions and
more in today's video
james sirius potter james serious potter
was harry and ginny's first born child
although we're not quite sure about when
he was born all records indicate that
his birth date falls between the summer
of 2003 and the fall of the following
year
as you can probably tell from his name
james sirius potter was born with quite
a powerful name
his first name was taken from his
paternal grandfather james potter who
was murdered by lord voldemort on
halloween in 1981 and his middle name
sirius was taken from harry's godfather
sirius black iii unlike harry's other
son albus james series potter never
seemed to mind the burden of his names
when harry named his children he decided
to honor the most important people in
his life
mainly that meant the many people who
sacrificed themselves in order to
protect him during voldemort's dark
reign
while harry's intentions might have been
honorable the burden of bearing those
names was often more than his children
could handle
but as we've mentioned james didn't
really seem to mind it all that much
little has been written about james's
childhood but we can guess a few things
since both of his parents were powerful
magic users james benefited by growing
up in a household rich with culture
unlike harry who was neglected by the
dursleys and kept ignorant of the
wizarding world
james was immersed in it it's easy to
imagine harry ginny and james taking
regular trips into the countryside to
visit their many friends and former
classmates who studied magi zoology in
the wilderness or when they didn't feel
like trekking into the wild perhaps the
potters went to diagon alley to do some
much needed shopping
ginny probably handed james a few coins
to buy a handful of cauldron cakes and
pumpkin pasties from sugarplum's sweet
shop
james's name first appears in written
records when he was 11 years old
along with the rest of his family he
took a once-in-a-lifetime trip to the
quidditch world cup
there harry once again used his old
connections to meet one of the most
famous quidditch athletes in the world
victor crum
he introduced crumb to his boys and
together they wore bulgarian jerseys to
show their support in 2015 james
received his letter of admissions from
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry by that fall he took his first
trip aboard the hogwarts express was
sorted as a gryffindor and began his
studies as a wizard
during his time at hogwarts james got
his hands on both the marauders map and
the invisibility cloak unlike his father
harry james was never dragged into any
memorable adventures and unlike his own
grandfather james potter the first the
younger james was never much of a bully
and actually seemed to be rather well
liked albus severus potter
albus severus potter was the second
child from harry and ginny's
relationship
albus was born only two years after his
older brother james before albus
enrolled in hogwarts the two boys had a
typical brotherly relationship
at times they were best friends and at
others they were bitter rivals
through it all they lived a quiet
peaceful childhood with splashes of
excitement like the time albus went with
his family to the quidditch world cup in
2014
although unlike james potter ii
albus was worried
he couldn't help but notice all the
stares he received from strangers when
they first heard his name
he was named after one of the most
powerful wizards in the world albus
dumbledore and one of the most important
spies of the second wizarding war
severus snape but albus severus potter
felt as though he couldn't measure up to
either legacy
and after failing to successfully
fulfill simple magical tasks that doubt
seemed to be proven true
in the fall of 2017 albus severus joined
his brother james on his journey to
hogwarts
this was albus's first year at school
and he was worried that his magical
inadequacies along with the heavy
scrutiny that a potter regularly
receives would make him an easy target
for bullying
overwhelmed with anxiety albus confided
in his father
in order to live up to the legacy of his
name albus presumed that he needed to be
sorted into gryffindor and while waiting
in front of platform nine in three
quarters albus's father harry reassured
the young boy that it didn't matter
which house he was sorted in as a matter
of fact the bravest person that harry
had ever known severus snape was a
slytherin so enrolling in that house was
just as honorable as any other after
hearing that reassurance albus turned to
board the train along with his cousin
rose granger weasley for much of his
life albus relationship with rose was a
fairly stable fixture but from that day
the two would soon grow apart rose just
like her parents hermione and ron would
become quite popular at school but albus
wouldn't fare as well
when he arrived at hogwarts albus was
sorted into sutherin a fact that made
him the target for bullies from all
houses gryffindor students considered
him a traitor and southern students
thought albus was simply ill-fit for the
house with neither side embracing him
albus relied on the one friend he made
aboard the hogwarts express for comfort
scorpius malfoy together the pair of
quasi outcasts dared to navigate social
life at hogwarts but they rarely
succeeded
even as a student albus discovered that
he couldn't even compare to the lowest
ranking pier in class
much less the great wizards albus
dumbledore and severus snape
unhappy with his achievements and
rejected by his peers albus's mental
health deteriorated year after year his
parents harry and ginny weren't entirely
ignorant to albus's struggles but they
didn't know how to help him
often harry would try to lift albus's
spirits by reciting old tales of harry's
childhood heroes and how they handled
adversity but every time albus heard
about remus dumbledore or hagrid the
shame he felt for not living up to their
legacy grew even worse
another time harry and ginny even asked
their friends hermione and ron to
encourage their daughter to rekindle her
friendship with albus but when rose
tried to reach out to her cousin albus
smartly realized that the gesture was
insincere and he rebuked her in the end
albus was left with only one choice
rebel
when a strange young woman named delphi
came into his life albus and his friend
scorpius decided to join her on an
adventure
together they would steal a time turner
and travel back in time to save the life
of cedric diggory
a boy who was senselessly killed during
the tri-wizard tournament decades prior
but albus and scorpius failed to ask
delphi a few important questions before
the journey began
and by the time their mission was over
the two boys realized too late that they
had been duped delphi was never really
interested in saving cedric's life she
wanted to travel back in time to save
the life of someone else lord voldemort
because she was his daughter
it took the combined effort of albus and
his father to undo delphi's plot
in the aftermath albus finally
understood how his father harry had felt
during the second wizarding war
instead of comparing himself to albus
dumbledore severus snape and the other
heroes who sacrificed their lives albus
seemed to simply feel grateful for all
that they did
lily lunapotter lily lunapotto was the
third and final child from harry and
ginny's marriage she was also their only
daughter which must have been a relief
after the headaches the two parents
received from albus and james's
roughhousing childhood
lily was born two years after albus
which meant she was four years younger
than james the oldest potter child
as you might have guessed lilly was also
named after one of the most important
people in harry's life
her first name was taken from harry's
mother lily whose deep magic was
responsible for both of voldemort's
deaths and her middle name luna was in
honor of luna lovegood a young witch who
aided harry on his journey to rid the
world of voldemort's horcruxes
when we look at the historical records
lily just like james doesn't seem to
show up too often
during her younger years she probably
spent her days doing the same things any
young witch would playing around the
house running errands with her parents
and getting herself into trouble as she
grew older though she became
increasingly fascinated with hogwarts
and the complex legacy that each of its
houses possessed
along with her cousin hugo weasley she
would often fantasize about which house
the sorting hat would select her for
by the year 2019 lily enrolled at
hogwarts and unlike albus who had been
sorted into slytherin lily was sorted
into gryffindor
joining her eldest brother james
and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
you